meine kolleginnen in würzbach ist seit
dieser woche auf der wohl schönsten
insel mallorca wo die deutschen gerne
urlaub machen und hat sich informiert
und testet wie urlaub auf der
balearischen insel funktionieren kanäle
wie läuft es läuft sehr gut wir sind
seit heute morgen hier denn heute hat
das pilotprojekt gestartet das kästen
soll wie urlaub eben trotz pandemie
funktioniert also bisher nur deutsch
wohl aber hier auf der insel und auch
nicht sehr viele wir wollen jetzt
trotzdem gucken macht es spaß wären
corona den urlaub zu fahren
die erste hürde natürlich heute morgen
der flug hierher hat sich gefragt hat
sich was geändert worauf müssen wir
jetzt ganz besonders achten
an diesen fragen sind wir hinterher
gegangen haben hinterher gefragt bei
unserem flug von düsseldorf nach
mallorca endlich hebt wieder ein
urlaubsflieger richtung mallorca ab am
montagmorgen war es soweit wenn auch mit
leichter verspätung konnte vom
düsseldorfer flughafen eine maschine des
reiseveranstalters tui nach mallorca
fliegen
ein historischer moment für die
beteiligten ja das hätten wir uns
wahrscheinlich auch nicht träumen lassen
dass einen flug nach mallorca mal ein
historischer moment sein wird aber es
ist so es ist der erste flug nach
mallorca jetzt nach drei monaten des
stillstandes das heißt jetzt können
pauschalreisende auch wieder eine
urlaubsreise entsprechend antreten
urlaub wird dieses jahr natürlich
entsprechend auch anders sein weil wir
uns im haben der abstands und
hygieneregeln natürlich auch im urlaub
anders verhalten wie wir das eben auch
zu hause machen im flieger wird die luft
durch die klimaanlage alle zwei minuten
komplett ausgetauscht für alle reisenden
besteht masken pflicht 165 passagiere
waren bei diesem flug mit an bord und
diese freuten sich auf die reise auf die
lieblingsinsel der deutschen
wir haben schon auf jeden fall längere
irgendwie jetzt unseren urlaub
verbringen kann weil der
unser urlaub strand fest und letzte
woche war dann ganz kurz 40 watt bei
ihrer suche und dann haben wir sofort im
reisebüro an diese pauschalreise gebucht
letztendlich ist es ja im rahmen des
sicherheitskonzeptes was ja auch sehr
gut organisiert wurde von den
reiseveranstaltern also insbesondere tui
hat hier
dieses sicherheitskonzept auch recht gut
betreut was wir also informiert werden
also per sms oder per e mail auch
instruiert werden also großartig angst
haben wir nicht weil es werden ja auch
nicht viele gäste auf die insel sachen
in einem ersten kontingent dürfen bis zu
zehn 1900 reisende aus deutschland auf
die balearischen inseln reisen
am nachmittag geht von frankfurt aus ein
weiterer flieger richtung mallorca vor
ort ist alles auf die sicherheit der
gäste ausgerichtet
wenn es also symptome bei einem gast
gibt dann wird der test das erste mal
durchgeführt sollte es einen positiven
test geben dann wird der gast in einen
anderen bereich des hotels ziehen oder
in auch ein anderes hotel gehen und
entsprechend dort von den behörden
betreut und danach wird dann festgelegt
wann eine rückreise nach deutschland
wieder stattfinden kann und unter
welchen bedingungen also dieses
protokoll hat man dann auch schon
detailliert für diesen fall vorbereitet
und so wie wir das in deutschland auch
kennen so wird es dann im ausland auch
angewandt für den fall der fälle wird
dennoch eine reiseversicherung angeraten
also wir kümmern uns um die rückführung
natürlich auch nach hause es gibt ja
immer auch reisekrankenversicherung die
wir den gästen ja auch immer empfehlen
für alle solche fälle eine entsprechende
versicherung einzureichen und die würde
das dann natürlich auch begleiten die
flughäfen erwarten dass nach aufhebung
der reisewarnung in die meisten
europäischen länder
der flugverkehr schrittweise wieder
zunehmen wird also heute gab es genau
zwei maschinen die hergekommen sind
deswegen habe ich auch das glück hier
fast ganz alleine an diesem strand zu
stehen ich stehe direkt am ballermann
diese jahreszeit ist es normalerweise
rappi dicke folie jetzt kann ich gleich
den sonnenuntergang fast ungestört
genießen sehen wollten wir natürlich
auch wissen was machen die ganzen
urlauber jetzt hier auf der insel die er
noch immer so ein bisschen im tiefschlaf
ist gerade erst aufwacht was
schreibt man also den ganzen tag und vor
allem wie sehr freut man sich dass mehr
endlich wieder zu sehen wir haben heute
zwei von den urlaubern begleitet ela und
jörg hauser aus bornheim bei frankfurt
haben vergangenen mittwoch spontan ihren
einwöchigen urlaub an der playa de palma
gebucht und sie sind jetzt schon
begeistert
ich sag mal da für diese zeit ist ja der
hammer preis leistungs verhältnis stimmt
das da müssen wir darüber reden auch der
arme
jetzt sitzen sie in der sonne auf der
terrasse ihres hotels doch in corona
zeiten ist hier vieles anders
überall stehen desinfektions spender am
eingang messen wärmebildkameras die
körpertemperatur und schlagen alarm wenn
keine maske getragen wird
[Musik]
das hotelpersonal trägt masken und
handschuhe für gäste gilt nur beim
empfang und am buffet eine masken und
handschuhen pflicht sie liegen am pool
stehen weit auseinander und bademeister
kontrollieren streng dass die
mindestanzahl an pool besucher nicht
überschritten wird
insgesamt darf das hotel nur 50 prozent
der üblichen kapazität aufnehmen am
strand können ela und jörg hauser
endlich ihren verdienten urlaub genießen
aber genau das ist der grund warum man
jeden schritt genau dass ich gar nicht
sagen
eins ist klar für die hauses wird das
nicht ihr letzter urlaub auf mallorca
sein
jan die euphorie kann ich nur teile ich
die ja gerade selber am strand und ist
das absoluter luxus wie lehrers hier ist
in meinen augen zumindest es ist immer
eine liege am pool und es gibt keine
schlange am buffet ja richtig gehört
befährt das gibt es hier trotz corinna
trotzdem selbstbedienung in einigen
hotels zumindest als pilotprojekt
besprochen wurde war das eigentlich
ausgeschlossen jetzt kann sich doch
jeder greifen was er will und das sogar
ohne plexiglasscheibe oder irgendwelchen
anderen schutz einfach nur handschuhe
und maske das reicht das nur eine von
den kuriositäten die mir hier heute
aufgefallen sind wir haben gerade schon
von den wärmebildkameras gehört die
wurden auch am flughafen schon genug und
eben hier in den hotels ich bin vorher
einmal fünf minuten draußen rumgelaufen
in der sonne heute wieder zurück ins
hotel und die kamera dann geschlagen und
gesagt da ist die körpertemperatur zu
hoch also muss man zwei drei minuten
warten bisschen fehlerhaft ist die ganze
sache also doch noch und vor allem die
korona test die vorher angekündigt
worden sind haben wir hier noch gar
nicht gesehen so ich sehe das wie ich
schon betonte arbeits absoluten luxus
das ist hier so leer ist aber natürlich
gibt es auch viele menschen die nach
mallorca kommen weil sie eben ein
bisschen stimmung und party wollen
deswegen die frage gibt es das jetzt
momentan die antwort darauf hat jetzt
mein kollege peter wege denn er steht
mit einem ganz besonderen gast in der
gaststätte zur krone peter mit wem bist
du und vor allem wie viel es bei dir los
an der krone direkt an der playa de
palma und hier ist auf jeden fall schon
mehr los als in den letzten wochen die
besitzerin beatrice hat am 11 mai gibt
schon aufgemacht dann war aber eher
weniger los aber heute mit dem tag wo
die deutschen wieder zurückkehren ist
auch gleich sehr viel mehr lust gäste
können hier ganz einfach essen ist es
läuft ähnlich ab wie in deutschland man
setzt sich hin
die kellner tragen masken ist wird
regelmäßig desinfiziert aber im
gegensatz zu deutschland gibt es keine
zettel wo man daten wie adresse oder e
mail adresse eintragen muss ja und jetzt
bei mir einer der gäste hier in der
krone ist schlagerstar peter wackel
peter wie hast du die deutschen
touristen hier heute auf mallorca
begrüßen wir sehr
die mbs für alle touristen die jetzt
angekommen sind wir stehen auch noch so
ein bisschen mit abstand auseinander und
genauso habe ich das heute morgen schon
gemacht habe 11 uhr habe ich mich
vorbereitet in der schinkenstraße und
habe also einen kreis um mich mit kreide
auf den boden gemalt eineinhalb meter
und habe also die ersten touristen die
dann so ab halb 11 uhr kamen die damen
mit großen begrüßt die haare mit t
shirts und mit strand beutel und habe
auch wirklich einzelnen städtchen
gesungenen lied wunsch wünsche dir von
einflüssen erfüllt ich habe den mann
aber scheiß drauf man löst nur einmal im
jahr gesungen
und ganz ehrlich es war mir eine ganz
große ehre und freude ich freue mich
über jeden gast wer jetzt wirklich im
ersten flieger saß und in den nächsten
tausenden fliegern die wieder auf die
insel kommen
wir merken die partystimmung ist hier
noch nicht ganz angekommen aber peter
wackel hilft tatkräftig mit dass das
schnell wieder der fall ist und damit
zurück zu dir an den strand ich will mir
ganz sicher es wird nicht lange dauern
und auch die party stimmung hier auf
mallorca zurück und dann gibt es
wirklich für jeden wieder etwas auf
dieser insel
die gute nachricht ist ab dem 21 juni
also nächste woche schon kann wirklich
jeder wieder hier ins land kommen nach
spanien nach mallorca egal ob man teil
des pilotprojektes oder nicht ja bis
dahin testen wie hier die insel noch ein
bisschen melden uns morgen früh
natürlich zurück und damit gebe ich
jetzt hier vom strand erst dann zurück
ins studio zu normen nach berlin
petronilla vielen lieben dank für eure
informationen ich glaube ich spreche für
alle hier aus berlin wenn ihr heute den
schönsten feierabend habt danke euch